But how do we tear this down and really
look at it with fresh eyes, right?
There's so many different opportunities.
Give me my iPad. Sure. iPad is an
interesting example of how it's causing
everything to be re reimaged.
Yeah, you're right. Yeah. And u you play
with the calendar, it's pretty
boring. And uh same thing with a lot of
newsfeed guys. Yeah. Then this Yeah,
exactly. this company called Flipboard
comes out and totally transforms what I
think a a Twitter feed looks like. Yeah.
But it's it just finds some news and uh
you know now it's beautiful, right?
Yeah. And you use your hand to touch it
and that's very different than using a m
everybody's like why can't they do this
on Windows? It's like cuz Windows has a
mouse, right? This is touch. This is I
mean you can even drag it slowly. Yeah.
And it's something about it is sensual,
you know, it's touch, you know, and uh
you know, you just page through it and
it's
design just by applying some design
principles to something that already
exists. It totally transforms it.
Totally changes it. So agreed. I mean,
it's the same information I've always
been looking at tweet or sees or
twitter.com. This doesn't look like
twitter.com. Sure. No.
You can even go and go to the
original articles and see how ugly it
is. It's like you eat beautiful land and
go to ugly land. You know what's cool is
you can see what other people are saying
about that article as well which is
interesting. Tweet are you using it as
primary source now? I mean I saw you
pull up Twitter. I don't even read
anything else. I mean that's
twitter.com. You know how it is. It's
like give me a break, you know?
And I think that that's one challenge
for you guys is the same thing. It's
like how do you take a fresh eye to it
and come up with something that's that's
a new design. You click on it zooms and
it has pictures and it has interactivity
and it has beauty to it, you know, and I
miss that. I I want my time calendar to
have the same kind of utility on on iPad
or on Android devices.
The other thing that we're looking I
mean, we've talked about a couple of
things, but kind of coming back to your
post. So, we've got all these
information silos out there that are
about you, whether it be your Yelp
preferences or your movie preferences,
your reading preferences. The difference
between where the calendar is now and
where we think it should be going is
that the calendar of the future should
really learn your preferences,
understand what it is that you do. Um,
and the net net of that, the information
flowing in is that we have a tremendous
amount of data about your interests, who
you are, where you spend your time. Um,
and so it's not just about the data
coming in, but then ultimately the
calendar should be able to provide you
with insight, right? So we've got all
this data. We're running a logorithms
behind it. You should be able to peg
your goals. This is I want this amount
of family time, this amount of travel
time, right? These are the goals I have
in terms of the way I spend my time.
We're now looking at, you know, the
actuals and we're measuring the
difference. We're able to say, listen,
for you to be most optimized in terms of
the way you spend your time, uh, these
are the kind of things that you have to
do. Yeah. I like to even go a little
simpler than that. Uh, you know, Google
Calendar and Tungle knows where I'm
going to be for each appointment. So,
like right now, it knows I'm here
because I put in Tungle is at my house
or or I can even put an address in it,
right? And if I'm going to be I'm in
Palo Alto this afternoon at the
Techrunch site this evening and
afternoon and so why would it let
somebody from San Francisco put anything
on my calendar because I'm going to be
between Half Moon Bay and Palo Alto and
it knows that and there's a couple hours
I'm not going to go to San Francisco in
that couple hours you know so if if you
guys can figure out an algorithm and say
hey that's not really an appropriate
time because you're in Salelo or some
other place in the world and he's going
to be in Palo Alto in San Francisco or
in and Half Moon Bay and Palo Alto and
we know that he's going to be between
those two places and you want to go
somewhere else. Yeah. Doesn't work.
Yeah. find another day that you know
he's going to be in S because there's
other days where I am in San Francisco
and it would be like oh it's only 15
minute drive from that other appointment
and and I I often you know schedule
things and then look at and go I was
really stupid for accepting that and and
then I have to delete it or you know
renegotiate. It's like I can't really do
it on that day. I have to move you to
this other day because I'm going to be
in San Francisco this other day and then
he's like oh I'm out of the country that
day. you know, it's like, oh man, now we
have to get back into the renegotiation
phase. And it's almost easier to go on
the phone and say, okay, just call me
up, right? We'll figure it out. Well,
there's some intelligence that we're
looking to build in fairly quickly. Um,
so location really being the key, right?
Um, the calendar should know that this
is your location, this is where you need
to be. Add automatic buffers onto your
meetings, right? Because just because
the meeting ends at 2 o'clock doesn't
mean you can accept at 210. Yeah. Right.
um and kind of getting that sort of
proactive data into the calendar. And
the same thing goes, you know, we had
meetings with Navtech. Yeah. To talk
about um you know, location data also
and points of interest and this kind of
thing. Um the calendar should know that
there's traffic and that what would
normally be a 20-minute drive today is
going to be 45 minutes, right? And
prompt you to leave early um and bring
feeds in that are going to help you be
more productive and more efficient.
Yeah. The other thing and I have a weird
job so it's it's gonna be hard to
translate this to other people but I go
around the world and interview tech
people right and I find I can do two
maybe three interviews if I'm doing
three every day right I'm burned out
right I it's too much so the way I solve
that is to just cut down the number of
hours that I'm available but that's
stupid because
I sometimes that second interview can
only happen at night so now I have to,
you know, somebody's like, "Your
calendar is booked for the next three
weeks because I blocked it all off, you
know, and now how do I get on there for
tomorrow night because I have something
sp like Saturday night, I'm actually
interviewing somebody because they have
an extraordinary iPad app coming out."
And it's like, okay, I want to see this.
I don't want to wait five months for to
see it. And so I stick them in there,
but I had to do that manually and off
off the tongi grid, right? It'd be nice
to say, you know, is this an interview
or is this a sushi dinner? You know,
these are the type these are the types
of meetings that I'm willing to break
the rules for. Right. Well, that's one
thing, but other thing is, hey, I've
already filled up my two two interviews
for the day, so I don't want to I don't
I can't do anymore, but I want to keep
the day open for other kinds of things,
you know, you know, this kind of stuff,
right? I mean, this isn't really an
interview. You could send people to one
page if it's interviews and another page
for social stuff, but but then you know
if if it gets booked there, it's no
longer there for people to be able to
pick from. That makes sense. So have
different types of likes or profiles or
Right. And or I can block out Yeah. Or
even I can block out, you know, and for
PR people I can block out a certain kind
of Yeah. And for my wife, she gets
different, right? It's uh yeah, that
makes sense because she she's allowed to
book me, but it's it's hard to do that
simply and the iPad told teach, you
know, Apple's teaching us if you have
too many features and you put too much
crap on the calendar and you lose it.
You lose, you know, any beauty that
you're going to have. That makes sense.
Then everybody's like, I'm not going to
use that. It's too complicated. And so
that's a an interesting challenge you
guys face. How do we fit more features
that solve these weird use cases, but
keep it simple and intuitive? And yeah,
how do you how do you make it so that
everybody goes, "Man, that's cool." One
thing that we we played with is that you
could you you put in your CC or BCC, you
know, the the name of, you know, an
assistant, like call it Betty at Tumble,
whatever. And and so you're replying to
the person saying, "Okay, yeah, I'd be
willing to meet with you. How about we
set up some some time between Friday and
Saturday in the evening or something? So
you can actually textualize it or or
whatever. And what happens is Tungle can
interpret what you do and actually send
the invitation out with the proposed
time based on your knowledge of your
calendar and then the person can just
pick a time within the parameters that
you did. So you didn't have to change
any of your habit. You just added
someone in a CC or BCC which is actually
a robot kind of thing. Yeah. The the
other way to look at this whole thing is
to do a mind shift. You know, I I
interviewed Siri. Have you guys have
seen Siri, right? On the iPhone got
bought by Apple. Yeah. And I'm hearing
that that's going to be the core of a
future iPhone, right? And Google's doing
the same thing. It's an AI play though.
It's an AI, but you talk to it. Uhu. It
understands your language or you could
poke at it and choose things from a
menu. But really the cool thing is you
talk to it, you say, "I need a taxi
tonight at 800 PM to pick me up here at
the house and it it understands it." So,
and you see that it understood your
language and then it uses artificial
intelligence to understand what was he
really trying to do, you know, and right
and he pulls out the keywords and the
key concepts of of what I was asking
for. And then it goes to web services.
And right now it doesn't have very many
web services. adds 40 or 50 and it but
it m it brings back information like hey
this taxi company can pick you up at
8:00 p.m. Here's the confirmation number
and here's right here's the taxi
driver's phone number. So here and it
knows the house is this address, right?
You're bridging two very important
concepts that that keep coming up for us
which is the idea that um there's a
shortage of time. You never have enough
time and there's too much information
and we're using mobile phone. We're
using these less and less the mobile
more and more and I hear that from every
entrepreneur who I mean I interviewed
Open Table and they said the mobile
usage is
just because people are out you know out
mountain biking or something and they
they have this brain fart. Hey, let's go
to dinner tonight. And so they, you
know, they they poke at a an app on
their iPhone or they talk to Siri and
say, "Find me a restaurant and boom, you
know, oh yeah, these three restaurants
have space tonight." You know, and it
makes that reservation right from the
cell phone. Sure. Um, spa finder if you
want a spa treatment or the spa at the
Ritz down here has a spa finder system
that manages their spa and has a
calendar, right? It's really
interesting. Open Table's a calendar and
spot finder is a calendar. You know,
it's their interface in front of it's
like, "Oh yeah, we have slots on at 8:00
and Saturday morning for you to come
in." Well, it's a web service. So Siri
could talk to it and say, "Hey, this guy
wants a a spa treatment in the morning,
tomorrow morning. Can you find me a slot
there?" And it, you know, it negotiates
back and forth and then he goes, "Oh
yeah, we found one at 8. Let's pull that
out and make a reservation." Mhm. And
that's something that doesn't look like
a when you're talking to Siri, it ain't
looking like a calendar, you know, it
doesn't look like that grid. Although
our data set, I would imagine would be
very important for Siri, right? Oh,
absolutely. Yeah. You know, and so
imagine a world where instead of 40 web
services or so that Siri is right now
talking to, you know, like Fandango,
Open Table, um, you know, a taxi web
service, pizza web service, stuff like
that. What if it had what if it was all
Apple applications, all 250,000 of them
automatically build an API that Siri can
talk to and negotiate with? Then what
happens to our world when we can talk to
an iPhone and have it negotiate with
everything in the world, you know, can
you uh change my flight on trip, you
know, and it knows, oh, he's on triet
because he has the triet app. Let's look
at triet. Oh, yeah. we found the flight.
Let's go to united.com. We know it. We
know his frequent flyer mile because he
has United Airlines app, you know, and
boom, all a sudden you create a magical
experience and and but it falls all the
way down the funnel, right? So, you make
this change with Tripid and now we see
you've moved your flight an hour. You
got to start moving meetings. You got to
start moving your car service and Right.
So, all of that has to that
reshuffleling has to happen dynamically.
Yeah. But do we you we may be too close
to the glass, right? So, but that you
know the question that we're asking
ourselves is is the calendar the hub for
all of this? Well, it sure seems like it
because like the spa salon has a
calendar that's a hub. Um, you know, the
restaurant trella has open table down
the street and that's a hub and that's
calendar, right? You know, and what else
is going to be a count? I'm going to
have my Google calendar or whatever.
Yeah. you know, whatever I find that's
cool. You know, you guys might take over
the world there.
We're trying. I will. Yeah. And Plancast
knows where I'm going. Plancast already
knows all the events I'm going to in the
next year. Yeah. Foursquare knows where
you are. Yeah. Foursquare knows where
you are. It's which isn't quite a
calendar, but it could be shoving stuff
onto a calendar interface. Our thinking
about the four square data is it's also
um it's data that would drive a
predictive engine, right? Or a
suggestive engine. So, uh you bring in
your four square feet into the calendar
now knows where you're checking in over
the past whatever 30 60 90 days. Yeah.
Then when you need that restaurant
suggestion for a lunch meeting, very
likely that the four square data will
know where the best bet is, right? Where
you should be. Yeah. And I I mean I just
started mountain biking, you know, and
um I have cycle meter, I think is the
app I use on my iPhone. I'm trying out a
bunch of different ones, but it's a
calendar. It's a map and a calendar with
a bunch of information about how fast I
was going. Really, right? Oh, it's
great. And you know, you share it on
Facebook. It's so interesting because
it, you know, while you're riding it
because it tells Facebook, Scoville just
started a ride, right? And then it goes
to Facebook and my friends comment on
Facebook and say, "Oh, great job,
Scubble. You're exercising fun." And it
reads those those comments to me while
you're on your while I'm on my Come on.
For real. For real. Wow. And you know,
and it's making a map. So every five
minutes they get to see how far I've
gotten. They can urge me out, you know,
go further, man. That's awesome. Don't
piss out
yet. You know, that is cool. It's cool.
And so when you add mobile and location,
everything it changes.